كما اود ان ارحب ايضا في هذا المكان
بانضمام جمهوريه توغو للتحالف ليصبح ضد
الدول الاعضاء في 86 دوله ومنظمه
وباعتباره اكبر تحالف دولي لمواجهه هذا
التنظيم الارهابي
خلال الاجتماعاتنا اليوم وناقشنا سبل
اعاده الاستقرار في الاراضي المحرره من
تنظيم داعش في سوريا والعراق باعتبارها من
ضمن قائمات لدى التحالف واكدنا على اهميه
استمرار الجهود في هذا الاطار كما اكد
المشاركون على الالتزامهم واستمرارهم في
الحد من مصادر التمويل الارهاب ووسائل
نشره والترويج كما تجد الاشاره هنا اذا
راس المملكه لمجموعه مكافحه تمويل داعش
وجهودها الكبيره في اطار تنسيق عمل كافه
الدول في التحالف للتصدي لتمويل هذا
التنظيم كما بحثنا الاجراءات التي يمكن
اتباعها لمجابهه الارهاب والمنشيات
المسلحه في غرب افريقيا ودول الساحل ووسط
وجنوب افريقيا والتي بدورها تزعزع الامن
والاستقرار في المنطقه وان المملكه ستشارك
في رئاسه مجموعه خاصه بافريقيا ايمانا من
التحالف
باهميه التركيز على هذا التحدي نظرا لما
يشكله
يعني مصدر للتهديد ليس فقط لدول الساحل
لكن لدول المنطقه اجمع والعالم وهنا اود
ان يؤثني على هذا التركيز المستجد على
التحدي التي تواجه القاره الافريقيه من
الارهاب واستشعارنا جميعا في المجتمع
الدولي بمسؤولياتنا تجاه التعاون والتنسيق
لمجابهه هذا التحدي كما اود ان اؤكد على
اهميه مجاجهه التنظيمات الارهابيه في
افغانستان لضمان ان لا تصبح مجددا ملاذا
امنا لهذه التنظيمات
وكذلك مهم ان نؤكد مره اخرى على ضروره
التزام المجتمع الدولي والطلاعي بادواره
في مواجهه تحديات المشتركه ومن ابرز
الارهاب والعمل على توفير البيئه الملائمه
بعوده النازحين في سوريا والعراق واجراء
الاصحاحات القضائيه لمحاسبه الارهابيين
واهميه اطلاع الدول الغنيه بمسؤوليتها
اتجاه عوده مواطنيها من مناطق النزاع
وحمايه الاجيال القادمه من اضرار هذه
الافه
وتبعاتها والحقيقه من المؤسف ان لازال
هناك عدد من الدول الغنيه
الدول المتقدمه التي ترفض استعاده
مواطنيها
وترمي بهذا العبء على دول المتاثره الاكثر
تاثرا بالارهاب المملكه تقوم بدورها
وتستعد كافه مواطنيها من مواقع الصراع
ونحن مستعدون ان نساعد من يحتاج فيما
يتعلق باعاده التحييل والانخراط المجتمع
لكن الدول كافه عليها مسؤوليه تحمل
ما قام به مواطنوها وان يستعيدونهم
ويرفعون هذا العب عن الدول المتاثره كما
اود في هذا المناسبه نؤكد على متاهه
العلاقه السعوديه الامريكيه التاريخيه
وما ناقشته مع صديقي توني البارحه في
لقائنا ثنائيه وكما ايضا تم مناقشته في
لقاء اسمه سيدي والعهد
في التشاور في القضايا ذات الاهتمام الشرك
الى تعزيز الامن واستقرار والدولي
واستعرضنا ملفات كثيره في المنطقه كذلك
اطر التعاون بين بلدينا وهناك مجال واسع
لهذا التعاون وسنستمر في بحث سبل
دعم هذا التعاون لما في مصلحه بلدينا
واود ختامنا اود ان نشير ان هذه نقطه مهمه
الحقيقه ان المشاركون اكدوا على ان التطرف
والارهاب في كافه اشكاله ومظاهرها يجب ان
لا يرتبط باي دين او جنسيه او مجموعه
عرقيه ولا يكون عذرا
لاتخاذ اي اجراءات او اي تفرقه او اي
عنصريه تجاه اي مجموعه عرقيه
وان لا يكون المسلمون عرضه لمضايقات مجرد
لان بعض الفئات ربما
انتهجت نهجا مخالفا وهذا ينطبق على جميع
العرقيات شكرا واعطي الكلمه للسيد توني
بنك
وزير الخارجيه فيصل اشكركم اشكركم على
ضيافتكم
وعلى جمع الشركائنا الاقليميه والدوريين
هنا في الرياض عندما سافر رئيس بايدن الى
جده في الصيف الماضي اكد على اهميه الشرق
الاوسط من اجل مصالح امريكا على المدى
البعيد ونحن ملتزمون بالاستمرار وتعزيز
شركاتنا في المنطقه معا نستطيع ان نحقق
التقدم لكافه شعوبنا ليس فقط لمعالجه
التحديات والازمات الحاليه
لصياغه رؤيا حاسمه لمستقبلنا المشترك عبر
الماضيه لقد حققنا هذا التقدم عبر عده
جبهات من خلال العامه وشركائنا السعوديين
وبجلس التعاون الخليجي والعمل اليوم مع
التحالف الدولي
لهزيمه ايداع الشعب الخارجيه لقد انهيت
اجتماعا بناء مع هذا التحالف الدولي
الولايات المتحده ممتنه لقياده المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ليس فقط في استضافتي هذا
الاجتماع بل لاسهاماتها المستمره
في كل يوم تحقيق هذه المهمه مع تحالفنا
يستعيد الاراضي اذا كانت يسيطر عليها داعش
وتكبدهم خساره فادحه في قيادتها فتبقى
داعش تهديد المستمرا اجتماع الوزاري ركز
على عده مجالات ضروريه
من ضمن تحقيق الاستقرار في المناطق
المحرره من داعش لكي لا تستغل الجماعه
الامن الضعيف او الظروف الانسانيه
والاقتصاديه
التي تترك
السكات كما اعتقد ياسين وكما سمعتم من
وزير الخارجيه
اعاده
الارهابيين الاجانب الى اوطانهم
نحن نعمل ايضا مع التهديدات الناشئه من
ضمنها جهود اذا عاش في شبه الصحارى
الافريقيه وداعش خرسان اعضاء الاتحاد 86
مركزين بشكل اكبر لاكمال هذه المهمه
للتخلص من داعش المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
مثلها اليمن عندما تولى رئيس بايدن
الاداره كانت الحرب مستعره وكانت تواجه
واوضع اسوا اوضاع انسانيه في العالم والان
نعمل بشكل مكثف مع السعوديه وشركاء اخرين
تحقيق هذا
الاستقرار في القتال الذي مدام على 14
شهرا اليوم في سنه الفرصه ايضا للقاء رئيس
اليمن
لمناقشه المسار المستقبلي هدفنا واهدافنا
دائم
وعمليه يمنيه شامله بواسطه الامم المتحده
والطالب العداله والمساءله
وبالختام تقود الى حل سياسي
بالخلافات في اليمن مفضل سوف يستمر بالعمل
مع الاطراف كان في المنطقه في الايام
السابع المقبل لحل المشاكل العالقه في وجه
السلام الدائم الولايات المتحده والسعوديه
لجان الخليجي تركز ايضا على نشاطات ايران
مزعزع المنطقه من ضمنها دعم الرهابي
والمليشياتها على السفن البحريه
هناك متحده تستمر
بايمانها الاجانب الضغوط الاقتصاديه ورد
او التعاون الدفاع يه القوي هي السبيل
الامثل لمعالجه ومواجهه هذه النشاطات
الخطره نحن ندعم جهود السعوديه
حول ازمه السودان امريكا
والسعوديه تقود حملات الدبلوماسيه لدفع
جانبين للالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار
وللسماحين بوصول لمساعدات الانسانيه الى
الشعب السوداني سوف نستمر بالعمل تجاه
تحقيق وقت اطلق نار دائم
وتشكيله قياده مدنيه انتقالي
اثيوبيا لمراجعه التطبيق الحالي
انهى الازمه
الاعمال
الى جانب التسويه او امريكا تستمر بتشاركه
مع ابنائي
السعوديه او الخليج علاقاتنا تمتد بعيدا
عن مجرد هذه التحديات فهي ضروريه جدا
لتوسيعيه الفرص والدفعي التقدم لشعبنا
ولشعوب العالم
وعبر الشركات التحتيه العالميه
والاستثمارات امريكا والسعوديه تعملان
التحتيه ذات الجوده العاليه
لمصلحه دولت تدخل المتوسط وحتى رقميه من
خلال التكنولوجيا الاتصالات
مثل الشبكات السحابيه الامنه وقليله
التكلفه نحن كافح ازمه المناخ ونسرع
الانتقال الى الطاقه نظيفه في المنطقه عبر
الشركات الثنائيه
في الصيف الماضي والذي يفك عنه طاقه
الهيدروجين النظيف والطاقه الشمسيه وغيرها
جانب اساسي من استراتيجيتنا
لتحق المنطقه المستقره وحول تخفيفي الى
توترات الخليج مترابطه الان اكثر من اي
وقت سبق كمنطقه وكذلك مع الدول الاخرى في
الشرق الاوسط من ضمنها اسرائيل امريكا
ستستمر بلعب بدور اساسي في تعزيز وتوسيع
عمليه التطبيع كما قال الرئيس بايدن في
جده الحقوق العالميه والحريات والحمايه
التي توفرها هي اولويه اساسيه لامريكا
وشراكه سعودي الامريكيه تتعمق خلال
تطور عمله حقوق الانسان لهذا اتخذنا خطوات
تاريخيه لتعزيز دور المراه في مكان العمل
والتسامح بين الزيادات المعتقدات ضمن
اجنده هذه الدوله طموحه
والان مع صله الزملاء من وسائل الاعلام
قناه العربيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان
هل التهديدات اليوم التي يشكلها تنظيم
داعش في بعض دول افريقيا وما دفع الاعلام
بانضمام السعوديه لرئاسه مجموعه التركيز
المعنيه بالشان الافريقي لمواجهه التنظيم
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
اجتماعات مع ولي عهد السعوديه الامير محمد
بن سلمان لس
وايضا اوضحت او كما وصفت انه اجتمعت معه
لساعات وناقشت معهم ملفات او ملفات كثيره
هل لنا ان نعرف بالتفصيل عن هذه الملفات
وايضا الملفات التي يرغ بها ولي العهد
السعودي مع امريكا شكرا
هاني
وانضمت المملكه لرئاسه المجموعه الخاصه
بافريقيا ايمانا من
بمسؤوليتنا تجاه الشراكه العميقه التي
تملك المملكه العربيه السعوديه مع القرن
الافريقيه قرر الافريقيه ننظر لها
كمصدر مهم
للتعاون والتنسيق والدول الافريقيه كلها
بالمجمل لها علاقه قويه بالمملكه العربيه
السعوديه ونحن مساهمون اساسيون في التنميه
في تلك الدول
ونستشعر بمسؤولياتنا تجاه الحفاظ على ما
حصل من تقدم في هذه الدول والتعاون معها
والتنسيق فيما يخص مجابهه هذا التهديد
الذي يهدد امنه واستقرار القاره كافه
وينعكس ح ايضا على امن واستقرار المملكه
العربيه السعوديه بحكم الجوار والمسؤوليه
مشتركه لمواجهه هذا التحدي بالذات ان كثير
من الدول الافريقيه ينقصها القدرات
التقنيه والمعرفه في هذا المجال
وكما واجهنا داعش في العراق وسوريا كمجتمع
دولي المسؤوليه ايضا ان نواجه التنظيمات
الارهابيه في القاره الافريقيه كمجتمع
دولي وبالتنسيق والتعاون
وسنعمل على ذلك وسندعم كل جهود الدوليه في
هذا الاطار
الا نكرر ما ذكره مع الوزير الخارجيه ومره
اخرى
هذا التحالف
الذي ضمسته وثمانين الدوله ومنظمه وهو
اكبر تحالف في العالم
وقد حققت تقدم نجاحا كبيرا جدا منذ عام
2014 في استعاده الاراضي التي سيطر عليها
داعش في العراق وسوريا
والتخلص من القيادات العليا لداعش
وتقليلي التهديد ولكن التهديد مستمر
والى جانب ذلك فهو
ينتقل الى مناطق اخرى وبشكل خاص من
افريقيا وهذا كان علينا ان نركز اليوم وفي
تحالفنا على بعض التحديات التي يواجهها
الشركائنا في افريقيا وبشكل خاص في الساحل
وغرب افريقيا
فالامر بتكره التعالف هو انه يتكيف ومرن
وحتى مع استمرار تركيزنا العراقي وسوريا
لضمان
عدم اعاده بروز تهديد داعش
يجب ان نضمن تركيزنا على مناطق اخرى قد
يكون فيه اكثر شاطا وكما ذكرنا الان هذه
المناطق افريقيا ولهذا السبب تركيز هذا
التحالف منصب على افريقيا بالشراكه
الكامله مع الدول الافريقيه
اخر شيء ودون اذكره وما هو جدير بالذكر من
نقاشاتنا اليوم وكل العام الذي قمنا به هو
ضروره المقاربه المكثفه الامن
الضروري ولكن هناك تحديات كيف بدنا
نواجهها من داعشن وسمعنا من شركائنا
فنظرات التعامل مع
المخاوفه واحتياجاتي المجتمعات المهمشه
وتوفير الفرص الاقتصاديه وضمان
وجود الحوكمه الجيده
والمقاربه السياسيه شفافه كل هذه الاشياء
الضروره لتحقيق نجاح ضد داعش ومنعها امن
التجنيد
والتوسعه في مناطق اخرى
السؤال الثاني
شكرا
معالي وزير الخارجيه صاحب السموم
السعوديه للحصول على الدعم لتطوير برامجها
النووي المدني بمقابله تطبيق علاقاتها مع
اسرائيل وهل تقولون بان هذا الشرط غير
قابل للتفاوض من اجل التطبيق والسؤال اخر
المملكه العربيه السعوديه قامت بالعديد من
الاصلاحات ان جماعتها حقوق الانسان افادت
عن عمليات اقامه وهي استجابتكم
ذلكم الامريكيين حول هذه المساله الوزير
بلانكن ناقشتمعه ولي العهد السعودي مثلا
التطبيع ما هو التقدم الذي حصل ومدى
امكانيه الوصول الى هذا الاتفاق انه ربما
عملت تسريع التسلح مع ايران وحلب
اي ضمانات من ولي العهد اتجاه اطلاق
المساجين السياسيين
شكرا جزيلا فيما يخص التعاون النووي ليس
سرا نحن نطور برنامجنا نوويه المدني
ونفضل ان
تكون امريكا متقدمه لتطوير هذا البرنامج
الدول الاخرى تتقدم مع سعينا بنايه هذا
البرنامج
افضل تكنولوجيا في العالم وهذا سيتطلب
اتفاق معين لدينا خلافات فرعي ونحن نعمل
على جاد اليه للعمل معا على تكنولوجيا
المدنيه والنساء المضي قدمت في هذا
البرنامج اما التطبيع وكما قلتم مسبقا
وواضح نحن نؤمن بان التطبيع يصب في مصلحه
المنطقه
وسوف يقدم فؤاد كبيره للجميع ولكن من دون
ايجاد السبيله للسلام لشعب الفلسطيني بدون
معالجه هذا التحدي فان اي تطبيق
سيكون له فوائد محدوده وبالتالي علينا
الاست مرار بالتركيز على ايجاد السبيل
اتجاه حلت دولتين
والمساره تجاه منحى الفلسطينيين الكرامه
والعداله
وامريكا لديها وجهه نظر مشابهه من المهم
جدا ان نستمر على هذه الجهود سالتي عن
حقوق الانسان والاصلاحات
ومن المعروف اننا قمنا او حققنا تقدمه
كبيره في الاصلاحات المملكه وما نقوم هنا
كله وفقا لتقييمنا فيما يصب في مصلحه
بلادنا وهو مدفوع باحتياجات ورغبات الشعب
السعودي انتم عشتم بعض الايام هنا واتمنى
ان تكونوا قد شاهدتم تغييرات الكبيره التي
حصلت في المملكه ولكن نحن دائما نفتحون
لخوض الحوار مع اصدقائنا ولكننا نستجيب
للضغوط عندما نقوم باي شيء نحن نقوم بذلك
حسب مصالحنا ولا اعتقد
بان اي شخص يؤمن بان الضغط مفيد
وبالتالي فهذا ليس بالشيء
الذي حتى سنه تم لها الاولويه هي تحقيق
الاهداف التي وضعناها لبلادنا نحن نركز
بشكل كبير على بناء المساره تجاهها
الازدهار المستدام بالشعب السعودي وانا
احسكم انتم وكل لديه اي فضول
لقضائي بعض الوقت في المملكه والتفاعل مع
الشعب السعودي واحكموا بانفسكم
فيما يخص التطبيع اولا وكما تعرفون نحن
ندعم بالكامل اندماج اسرائيل في الشرق
الاوسط
منذ اليوم الاول
ونحن نعمل من اجل تعذيب بعض العلاقات
القائمه اصلا وكذلك لتوسيعها مع دول اخرى
وهذا يشمل المملكه العربيه السعوديه اعتقد
ان هذه السكون خطوه هامه جدا للمستقبل
وبلا شك ستكون اولويه وهي بالفعل اولويه
بالنسبه لنا الاندماج جيد للمنطقه باكملها
وسوف نستمر لتحقيق ذلك ناقشنا ذلك هنا
وسوف نستمر
بالعمل عليها وتحقيقها في الايام
والاسابيع والاشهر المقبله اما فيما يخص
المواطنين الامريكيين وحقوق الانسان بشكل
عام اسمحوا لي انا اقول اولا
حقوق الانسان دائما على جده الولايات
المتحده
كما اوضحنا بان التقدم في حقوق الانسان
يقوي علاقتنا
وسوف ان استمر بالتحدث عن ذلك بشكل عام
وخاصه عن حقوق الانسان
هنالك شيء اخر في غايه الاهميه وقد ذكره
مع الوزير الخارجيه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه انطلقت في جهود
جباره وتاريخيه لتحديث
اقتصادها
ومجتمعها
وجزء من ذلك
سيجلب افضل المواهب بكافه انحاء العالم
الى السعوديه لزيارتها والسعيد التعلمي
هنا والاستثمار
والمشاركه والعمل الى جانب السعوديين
ومن وجهه نظرنا تان رؤيه 2030 كما سمى هذه
المبادره
ستحقق نجاحا اكبر بكثير اذا ما كانت
السعوديه اكثر مكانا جذابا لكف سكان
العالم المجيئي اليها وبالتالي
اعتقدوا بان حسب وصفها ومن مصلحه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ان تستمر
بالسعي لهذه هذا التحديث وتوسيع الحقوق
الانسان اما فيما يخص المواطنين
الامريكيين كما تعرفون كما ذكرت مرارا ان
رفعها وان المواطن الامريكي في كل مكان
حول العالم هو اولويتي القصوى ومسؤوليه
وهذا هو التركيز وزاره الخارجيه ايضا نحن
مستمرون
بالعمل نيابه عن الافراد قدر الامكان
وتسنت لي الفرصه
لطرح بعض المسائل ولن اخوض في المزيد من
التفاصيل
السلام عليكم محمد محمود من قناه سكاي
نيوز عربيه سؤالي الاول موجه لسمول امير
في الملف السوداني بعد الجهود السعوديه
الامريكيه المشتركه
والحث على عقد هذه الاتفاقيات التي تمت في
جده ما القادم من الجهود الدبلوماسيه
خصوصا مع استمرار الاشتباكات داخل الاراضي
السودانيه السؤال الاخر لمعالي الوزير
بلنكن قلتم في كلمتكم صباح هذا اليوم
باننا لا نريد ان تصبح افغانستان ملاذا
امنا للارهابيين كيف يمكن ان نوفق بين هذا
الكلام وبين الانسحاب الامريكي من
افغانستان الذي فتح المجال امام التنظيمات
الارهابيه والاعمال الارهابيه اخرها صباح
هذا اليوم تفجير في مسجد في افغانستان نتج
عنه 18 وفاه و33 اصابه شكرا لكم شكرا
بالنسبه للسودان
نعبر عن خالص شكري للتعامل الكبير الذي
حظينا به من الجانب الامريكي في المحادثات
التي
وصلت في جده للمحاوله
للتعامل مع الوضع الانساني والحرج نتيجه
لما حصل من اقتتال داخل السودان
حققنا بعض النجاح لم يكن نجاحا كاملا لان
الاطراف لم يلتزموا التزاما كاملا ونستمر
في العمل لبحث السبل لرفع المعاناه عن
الشعب السوداني عن طريق الوصول الى
تفاهمات معينه مع الاطراف هناك بوادر
ايجابيه حتى اليوم في المحادثات قد نصل
الى هدنه اخرى مع اليات مراقبه اكثر تشددا
تساعدنا في تحديد مواطن
الخلل او المخالفه ان حصل ذلك وان التزم
الاطراف سيكون ذلك بصيص عمل جديد لاخواننا
في السودان وهنا اوجه كلامي مره اخرى الى
الاشقاء في السودان كافه ان الدم السوداني
غالي وان لابد ان نعمل جميعا على
معالجه هذه الازمه بالحوار وعيدا عن
السلاح لان السلاح لا يحل شيء ولن يفضي
الى سواء مزيد من الدمار ومسيد من
الابرياء يسقطون
فنتجه الى الحوار نتجه الى معالجه الامور
من خلاله ونمتنع عن تعريض المدنيين الى
الخطر باستمرار هذا القتال بذات انه
القتال في المناطق المدنيه وانا واثق ان
الاخوه في السودان
سيتحملون مسؤولياتهم وسيقومون بما يجب
لتجريب المواطن السوداني مزيد من الدمار
والخراب هو مره اخرى سنعمل مع اصدقائنا في
امريكا وكافه شركائنا في المنطقه
واخرون للدفع في هذا الاتجاه
لاطول حرب من اننا سنستمر بالتركيز
على مصالحنا الامن القومي لمن عمليات
الارهاب الناجمه عن افغانستان ضرورين سوف
نتصرف ونعمل على التعامل معها وقد اظهرنا
ذلك بشكل جليل في الاشرقيه الماضيه قدرتنا
على فعل ذلك من ضمنها التخلص من احد كبار
قياداتي القاعده الذي يسكن في افغانستان
او يقوم في افغانستان على ذلك نحن نعمل
مشاركة ودول الجوار لتعزيز القدرات
للتعامل مع اي عمله ترهابيه قد يكون مقرها
في افغانستان
او تنجم من هناك وفي نفس الوقت
الطالب عنه
عدو لدع شخص
ويعمل ضد هذه الجماعه وبغض النظر عن ذلك
فقد اوضحنا
واظهرنا قدراتنا المستمره للقيام بها
اعمال
تحمي امننا ضد اي ارهاب قد ينجم من
افغانستان
البصمه امريكا العسكريه المخافه في
المنطقه هل وفرت الفرص للصين لتعزيز
علاقاتهم العربيه السعوديه واخرين ثانيا
امتقد اعاده الاندماج لسوريا للمنطقه قال
بان بشار الاسداء ذلك حل
حدثت العربيه السعوديه شروط مقابله عوده
السعوديه الاحظ العربيه الوزير بلانكا هل
تخشون ان الصين
يعتمد عليها اكثر من امريكا في المنطقه
وفيما يخص سوريا امريكا
طلبت الدول التي طبعت علاقاتها ان تحصل
اشياء بمقابل التطبيعها مع الاسد حل انها
جماعه تطبيعة عن اي تنازلات
ثانيه اكبر اقتصاد في العالم
وهي اكبر شركه تجاري بشكل طبيعي هنا
الكثير من التفاعلات والتعامل مع الصين
لانها شريكها من المملكه ولاغلب الدوليه
المنطقه واعتقد ان هذه الشراكه
وهذا التعاون على اكثر سيئم بسبب باثر
الصله الاقتصادي على المنطقه لانه ايضا مع
زياده المواصين ولكن الاعزاء لدينا شراكه
انديه قويه مع امريكا وهذه الشراكه
الامنيه
نعيد تجديدها وانعاشات كل يوم تقريبا
ولدينا تمارين عسكريه مستمره والدينا
التعاون مشاركه معلومات الاستخباراتيه كما
نرى في الجهود في السودان
في اليمن هذه الشراكه مع ملكه تبقى قويه
خاصه في تلك المجالات والمناطق فانا
الا اقول بانها هي لعبه صافي صافري بل نحن
قادرون تكوين شراكات وتفاعلات متعدده
وامريكا تفعل نفس الشيء في حالات عديده
فانا لا امر بهذه النظره السلبيه فنحن
نستطيع ان نبني شراكه تتجاوز هذه الحدود
وقد سمعت بيانات من امريكا حول الرغبه
لايجاد السبل لتعاون افضل حتى مع الصين
ذلك لا نشجع ذلك لاننا نرى ان
التعقل
وهذا يعني التعاون بين الجميع فيما يخص
سوريا من المهم جدا ان ندرك السياق السياق
حواء ان الوضع الراهن لم يكن ناجحا وكان
عبء المتزايد على دول المنطقه وعلى الشعب
السوري بغض النظر عما عن وجهه نظر اتجاهها
بشار الاسد فن المسار الوحيده لحل
التحديات الانسانيه التي نواجهها في
الازمه السوريه هي لايجاد المسار لمعالجه
مشاكل اساسيه
الاخرى كيف نضمن وجود مسار امن لعوده
اللاجئين
ووجود بعض اله التسويه السياسيه او مشكله
المخدرات كل هذه الامور تتطلب الحوار مع
دمشق
ربما قراته
في عمان
قبل العوده الى جامعه الدول العربيه واوضح
وقدمت سوريا التزامات واضحه جدا في كل تلك
المجالات العامله معنا ومعالجتها بشكل
يلبي اعمال ليس فقط اعمال نحن في المنطقه
بل حتى المجتمع الدولي
والان سوف نعمل على تلك الالتزامات التي
قدمتها دمشق في الختم يجب ان نفكر في
المساله الانسانيه والشعب السوري
وكيف ان نرفع عنهم المعاناه التي يعيشونها
ونحن نؤمن بان هذا وافضل مسار قدما اما
الجهود الاخرى فقد
فشلت عن تحقيق اي تقدم على
زادت صعوبه الاوضاع مثلا لبنان الذي يعيش
اقتصاديه صعبه جدا
فليس بسحيم حول هذا اللعب مليونير سوري لا
استطيع تحمل هذه اللعبه طويلا يجب ان
نتجنب الوضع الذي يضعهم في خطر فيجب ان
يعود بامان نحن نؤمن بان هذا المسار قد
ينجم ويمكن ان ينجم على التاج
بينما فشلت الجهود الاخرى نحن نعمل مع
امريكا واخرون
كلها ضمن اعمال المجتمع الدولي
التماشيا مع قرار المجلس الامن الذي له
الصلاه بالامر
فيما يخص الصين
بمطابق تماما اللي جواب معالي الوزير
الخارجيه اولا في المنطقه وشراكاتنا
وعملنا هنا لا يدور او ليس علاقه بدوله
اخرى بل له علاقه بهذه الشركات والمصالح
من خلال العملي معا شعوبنا
ونستطيع حتى تحديدا ان نقدمها للشعب
العالم وقد وصفت بعضها مسبقا وفي نفس
الوقت بشكل خاص فيما يخص الصين
لقد اوضحنا اننا لا نطلب لاي طرف ان يختار
بين الولايات المتحده او الصين فقط نحاول
ان نظهر
فوائد شراكتنا
والاجندن
الحاسمه التي نقدمها وما نحاول فعله
وكل ما سمعته على مدى العامين ونصف
الماضيين وحتى الايام الثلاثه الماضيه
من الشركاء حول المنطقه والعديد منهم
كانوا حاضرين هنا في رياض الولايات
المتحده تبقى
الشركه المفضله لاغلب دول المنطقه
فيما يخص سوريا
مره اخرى ليس سرا نحن لم نعتقد
بان اعاده اندماجيه سوريا
ولكن في نفس الوقت نحن نرى بين اهدافنا
متشابهه فيما يحاول تحقيقه موقفنا واضح
جدا
لن نطبع العلاقاتي مع الاسد ومع هذا
النظام لانه لم يستحق هذه الخطوه تجاه
الاعتراف بها والقبول به
ولكن
لان الاهداف متطابقه تقريبا فاعتقدوا بان
من اجل مضي قدم وكما وصف مع الوزير
الخارجيه فربما سنحقق بعض التقدم وكلنا
نرغب التوصل الى حل في سوريا
يتطابق مع قرارات مجلس الامن 22 54 نوسع
امكانيه الوصول لمساعده الانسانيه الى
الشعب السوري ونضمن عدم
بروزي 11 مره اخرى ونريد الظروف الامنه
لعوده اللاجئين
ومكافحه تهريب مخدرات الكرتون لا تسببه
اضرار كبيره في المنطقه وتقليل نفوذ
الايراني
فما سمعنا وما سمعتموه مره اخرى من الوزير
الخارجيه هو نيه شركائنا لاستغلال يتفاعل
باشر مع النظام الاسد من اجل تحقيق المزيد
من التقدم في هذه المجالات ومجالات اخرى
خلال الاشهر القادمه
على ان اعتمد باننا متشككون من رغبه الاسد
في اتخاذ الخطوات اللازمه ولكننا متوائمون
مع شركائنا هنا حول ما هي تلك الخطوات
وحول الاهداف النهائيه
شكرا جزيلا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات